طبعا نرصد اثار الدمار من داخل مقر قناه
الجزيره بعد واثر قصف اسرائيلي مباشر لهذه
القناه الان غرفه المونتاج هي مدمره بسبب
هذا القصف الاسرائيلي المباشر هذه اثار
الدمار في غرفه المونتاج ايضا في اقسام
الاخبار والاقسام الاخرى غرفه الاجتماعات
ايضا مدمره بالاضافه الى هذه الغرفه هي
تابعه لغرفه الاخبار هي ايضا مدمره هذه
اثار القذيفه الاسرائيليه التي سقطت بشكل
مباشر على قناه الجزيره مما تسبب ذلك
بدمار كبير جدا في داخل المقر هي ليست
القذيفه الوحيده التي سقطت هناك الكثير من
القذائف
التي سقطت هنا ايضا اثار قذيفه هذه غرفه
الاخبار غرفه الاخبار مدمره بشكل كبير جدا
بعد قصف الغرفه بشكل مباشر هذه اثار ايضا
الشظايا القذيفه الاسرائيليه التي سقطت
على مقر قناه الجزيره في مدينه غزه نحن
الان في اعلى مكان في مدينه غزه وهو برج
الطباع هذه صوره شيرين ابو عاقله التي
قتلت بسبب القصف الاسرائيلي لم تغيب صوره
شيرين رغم القصف والدمار والركام
وا اثار البارود لن تغيب صوره شيرين كما
لن تغيب قناه الجزيره عن هذه التغطيه
الحيه
والمباشره يستمر العمل بعد قتل وقصف قناه
الجزيره قتل قناه قتل قوات الاحتلال لسامر
ابو دقه وشيرين ابو عاقله والان تستمر
التغطيه رغم ايضا قصف قوات الاحتلال في
مقر قناه الجزيره قناه الجزيره لم تسلم من
هذا القصف كما لم تسلم عائلات واهالي
الزملاء في قناه الجزيره من القصف
الاسرائيلي المباشر هذا الدمار هو من اثار
القصف الاسرائيلي على قناه
الجزيره